احد الحره هنا اكد ان المصنع احرق بفعل
فاعل بعد نهده عقب انتشار لمن يصفهم
بالمتفلتين المستغلين لاضطرابات الامنيه
في المنطقه وعما الضرر كثيرا من اجزائه
ومخترياته الحريق من وين والله ما عارفه
كم يوم في حريق هنا
اللهم صل على النبي
بتاع العاديات
هذا المصنع تابع لاحدى اكبر شركات تعبئه
المواد الغذائيه في السودان رفوف خاويه
ونهب شمل حتى المواد الخام
حاجات كثيره كل مره ما يخش لنا جوه بعد ما
اخش جوه يقول لنا
الكراتين دي فيها شنو
كلها
عادي
زيارتنا هنا لمنطقته الصناعات وكنا نعد
ونصور في هذا التقرير اندلع حريق في هذا
المصنع هذا المصنع للمواد البلاستيكيه
وتبدو اثار الحريق ونتائجه كبيره نسبه
للدخان الذي نراه متصاعدا من هذا المصنع
ما ان تخمد النار في مصنع حتى تشتعل في
اخر
الحرائق المتكرره اندلعت في عده مصانع
ومخازن في المنطقه الصناعيه ببحري منذ
بدايه المواجهات مثل مصنع الطلاء هذا الذي
ذاب سقفه الحديدي ولم يبقى من مخزن اثاث
شركه ابي الفاضل سوى الجدراني وكومه رماد
حراس هذه المنطقه لمن التقينا بهم يرون ان
الحرائق تجري بفعل ممنهج بعد النهب من قبل
لصوص قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها نشرت
وحدات لتامين المنطقه الصناعيه لوضعها الد
لهذه الافعال خسائر باهضه اللاحقه قطاع
الانتاج ومرافقه صناعيه في السودان نتيجه
تداعيات المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع خسائر سيكون لها اثار وخيمه في
اقتصاد البلاد وانسانها
محمد الطيب الجزيره المنطقه الصناعيه
الخرطوم بحري